now at first glance reducing the payload
of each transfer and only transmitting
data when it's required seems like a
sound approach you're reducing the
amount of data being transferred so
that's less data on the network and it's
less superfluous work being done story
and processing that data on the device
it's basically a case of putting off any
work until you know you actually need to
do it but it turns out that this
approach has some drawbacks compared to
the big cookie model of doing all of
that work upfront so overall this is a
better solution but let's take a closer
look at the big cookie model and to do
that we really need to understand the
underlying cell radio state machine